wasserstoff dieses farblose und
geruchslose element soll unsere
energieversorgung unabhängiger und
klimafreundlicher machen aber wie genau
in diesem video erklären wir wie
wasserstoff energie funktioniert
wo sie eingesetzt werden soll und welche
neuen abhängigkeiten druck
wasserstoffatome begegnen uns überall
aber nie allein sondern immer gebunden
am häufigsten in form von wasser also in
verbindung mit sauerstoff
um den wasserstoff abzutrennen ist das
gebräuchlichste verfahren bisher die
elektrolyse
dabei wird mit hilfe von strom das
wasser zerlegt in wasserstoff und
sauerstoff
die elektrische energie wird also in
chemische energie umgewandelt und im
wasserstoff gespeichert dabei geht aber
auch ordentlich energie verloren
wasserstoff ist also keine energiequelle
wie erdöl erdgas wind wasser und
sonnenlicht sondern ein energieträger
ein knackpunkt der aufgewendete strom
zur herstellung von wasserstoff müsste
nicht etwa mit gas oder kohle generiert
sein sondern klimafreundliche generativ
der so genannte grüne wasserstoff
du so werden wir unabhängiger und kommen
beim klimaschutz voran
derzeit wird in deutschland jedoch nur
ein geringer teil über elektrolyse
verfahren extra erzeugt der überwiegende
teil des wasserstoffs wird als
nebenprodukt in der industrie erzeugt
dabei wird beispielsweise der
wasserstoff aus erdgas getrennt der
sogenannte graue wasserstoff
um gewonnene wasserstoff energie zu
speichern und zu transportieren muss
diese wiederum gebunden werden mit
kohlendioxid oder stickstoff
power tricks nennt man diese verfahren
power also die anfängliche strom energie
wird in form von h2 unter hohem druck zu
gas zusammengepresst und den
druckbehältern aufgebaut oder in
flüssiger form dabei wird das h2 mit co2
also kohlendioxid gebunden und in
spezialtanks gelagert aus diesem prozess
heraus können synthetisch hergestellte
kraftstoffe entstehen um zb normales
diese zu ersetzen war sie ein diesel
nachteile mit jedem solcher
umwandlungsprozesse sinkt die
energieeffizienz der strombedarf vor
allem zu beginn ist hoch und viele
wasserstofftechnologie sind noch nicht
marktreif bisher
wasserstoff zu erzeugen und dann zu
nutzen ist noch zu teuer also nicht
wirtschaftlich fossile energien waren
bislang einfach günstiger
das möchte die bundesregierung und auch
die eu-kommission bis 2030 ändern ein
wasserstoff markt mit entsprechender
infrastruktur soll ausgebaut werden
dieser soll die industrie den
schwerlastverkehr und teile des
wärmemarktes mit wasserstoff besorgen
erster schritt klimafreundliche
erzeugung von strom aus solar- und
windenergie sollen stark ausgebaut
werden
so kann mit dem strom der nicht ins
normale netz eingespeist wird grünem
wasserstoff hergestellt werden dafür
braucht es wasserstoff fabriken die eben
energieeffizient arbeiten
beispiel chemie industrie ihr könnte
bereits heute grauer wasserstoff ohne
viel anpassungen durch grünen
wasserstoff ersetzt werden
beispiel schwerindustrie hier braucht es
zwar technische anpassungen aber dann
könnte auch hier wasserstoff genutzt
werden
das vorhandene gasnetz und die speicher
müssten ausgebaut werden in deutschland
sind bisher maximal zehn prozent reinem
wasserstoff beimischung ins erdgasnetz
erlaubt für den werbemarkt und damit
auch teilweise für unsere heizung zu
hause machen und regionale lösungen sind
also kleine h2 insel netze die genau
abgestimmt sind
mobil durch wasserstoff das ist vor
allem dann sinnvoll wenn normale
batterien zu groß und zu schwer sind
angefangen bei hat zwei bussen über
lastwagen schiffe bis hin zu flugzeugen
das potenzial ist da aber die
technologie noch nicht überall markt
teilt zu guter letzt die wasserstoff
systeme müssten immer streng überwacht
werden in wasserstoff in seiner reinform
ist hoch entzündlich
[Musik]
für die energiewende wird in den
nächsten jahrzehnten enorm viel strom
gebraucht eben auch um wasserstoff
herzustellen
die lokale erzeugung wird am ende nicht
reichen es braucht also eine verteilt
struktur im in und ausland
in ländern mit mehr sonne oder wind
könnte man besonders günstig strom
gewinnen und in form von wasserstoff
über pipelines schiffe oder lkws
transportieren
das meerwasser für die elektrolyse
müsste man teilweise erst entsalzen also
große entsalzungsanlagen bauen
gute bedingungen in der europäischen
union liegen bei mehr als der hälfte der
mitglieder
außerhalb beispielsweise in marokko
ägypten somalia und chile das aber
schafft neue abhängigkeiten von
funktionierenden handelsbeziehungen und
der politischen stabilität in den
ländern wichtig eine abhängigkeit mehr
von nur einigen wenigen ländern schaffen
wasserstoff technologie ist jetzt
politisch gewollt neu ist sie nicht für
eine erfolgreiche umstellung auf h2
technologie muss die herstellung
günstiger nachhaltiger und energie
effizienter werden und dafür eine
infrastruktur geschaffen werden mit mehr
wasserstoff könnten wir dann zunehmend
auf kohle öl und erdgas 40